a Florida sheriff's deputy is out on J
is out of jail rather on bond this
morning after a shocking video showed
him slamming a teenage girl to the
ground there's surveillance footage
caught thirty eight-year-old school
resource officer look at that Willard
Miller manhandling the 15 year old girl
at a school for children with special
needs he is charged with one count of
felony child abuse without without great
bodily harm he's now been suspended
without pay mola lang he's across the
street from Cross Creek school that's in
Pompano Beach Florida although this
video is very tough to to watch what
more do we know about this story oh yeah
good morning Gail the incident happened
here back in September here at this
school as you mentioned four students
with behavioral and emotional issues now
because the video is silent we can't
hear exactly what was said in the room
but while this investigation is ongoing
the Broward County Sheriff says that the
officer's actions were unacceptable just
after 2:00 p.m. on September 25th school
surveillance video shows a 15 year old
girl waiting inside an office with an
officer and two other adults you can see
the student lightly kick the officer in
the back of the knee causing his leg to
slightly buckle but a minute later the
officer rushes over grabs her around the
neck and slams her to the ground he then
turns her over puts his knee into her
back and holds her hands behind her
before throwing her into another room
the way the deputy responds for whatever
occurred whatever type of verbal
dialogue was going on it makes no sense
and it wasn't necessary school resource
officers nationwide have come under
increasing scrutiny for several recent
excessive force claims involving young
children in New Mexico a resource
officer resigned after body cam video
from August showed him tackle an 11 year
old middle school student to the ground
and in September an Orlando officer was
fired after he arrested two
six-year-olds at school back in Broward
the Sheriff's Department is focused on
fixing its own problems just this year
Sheriff Gregory Tony fired this deputy
for punching a handcuffed man in the
hospital and he suspended two deputies
without pay for
and pepper spraying a 15 year old boy in
a McDonald's parking lot if I have to do
this 15 more times we're gonna do it 15
more times and to those small fraction
of people out there and deputies who
don't get it
or held accountable and we're gonna move
them off the Broward County Sheriff's
Office is conducting an internal
investigation before deciding what steps
to take next with the officer in this
latest incident including possible
termination if convicted the deputy
Miller faces up to five years in prison
Anthony all right mama thank you as hard
as that video is just watch it's good
that we have it so we know what happened
but I've showered county normally in
those situations sometimes in those
situations officials say well you
haven't seen the whole tape there's
motive part of the story he's saying
what we just saw whatever has not
accepted my mother is a special
education teacher those jobs are full of
tough calls but the one we saw on that
tape was not a tough call right